[Music]
foreign
you know both of my size my grandparents
right they migrated my dad came here
when he was little and my grandmother
came here you know in the 60s right so
that's it you know just pure that that's
how I was born raised and and I was born
in in East Los Angeles which people
don't know that's pretty much like
Little Mexico right there brother like
we've been [__] there since the
[__] this [__] has been [__]
colonized you know what I'm saying like
whenever that [__] act happened like
boom this is the East Side that's where
we're at right and so I know nothing
different than that you know what I'm
saying I I I used to go to the stores
hearing Spanish and you know so it's
just this this this America that is
unlike any other [__] America
straight up right yeah and um seeing the
mural seen the Virgin seen all these
[__] colors that this is my America
yeah I don't and but also with these
communities it's it's a broken Community
right so what I believe believed Society
it's all it's not just America right
it's these these
these communities these cultures that
are not of the colonizer whoever
colonized the [__] land right but if
you are not of that they put you in a
place and you [__] just happens and and
so for me it's is right to me it's
ghetto it's the poverty it's and that's
what it is but could you feel that I
mean as a youngster could you feel that
[__] but I couldn't feel that [__]
because again don't you think that's the
norm right this is what it is right but
then when you fully
understanding the [__] sickness of
communities right when you start
understanding that like what the [__]
why all the men in my family have been
in prison
why has my community continue to suffer
why are all my uncles on drugs why are
all the neighbors wider are my friends
why when you start [__] thinking like
that right when and for me that didn't
happen until prison that didn't happen
until I was [__] set in a [__]
cage where my mind was able to start
thinking right but yeah bro that's that
that's the reality a broken childhood
broken community and and my family has
been involved in gang since the 1970s
what specifically what what gang have
what were you guys also my fam my
family's from one of the original the
oldest gangs probably in the United
States
um it's the projects of being Inc um
called the Estrada courts it's actually
where will I am came out of right to
right he was one of the you know he was
one of the few African Americans on that
side back then you know and um so it's
the projects and so what what the
projects were originally was um the
1940s when all those World War II vets
were coming out they put these housing
projects in the big cities rates or
um one of them was the Estrada courts
right how big is how big is the strata
course would you say like how many
people are living there roughly
thousands thousands thousands right so
it's almost like a mini it's like a mini
City within right right right yeah bro
it's not like and the thing about the
projects like the East Coast projects
and the West Coast projects like these
schools are high these are more spread
out from the West of Mississippi yep
that type of [__] were more spread out
it's like a village exactly exactly
exactly it's that type of [__] it's that
New Orleans type of [__] it's a
Louisiana type of [__] right so um so
yeah bro that's from that's where my
family came from
um and then I wouldn't be directly
involved in that game but I I am you
know we we would just continue
it's like this bro what happened so
gangs in east alley have been around I
mean 1940s bro right we've had a lot of
people that have been been involved in
that where do you think they came from
what what do you think they're the
original purpose was what was bro it's
Tribal right it's [__] tribal right
it's a society you must belong to your
people right who are your [__] people
writing if you don't belong to a people
you're gonna get hurt sure
something's gonna happen to you right if
you don't get what you're cruel bro
that's just what it is right and what do
you think back in the 40s did you hear
any stories about how that originated
what were the risks who was coming to
hurt you so so I only
could Link in from direct source right
and so this is
you have these beautiful murals right
and I and a [__] of of people playing
a [__] you know what I'm saying of our
culture and [__] right but in my mind
when I grew up none of that [__] existed
right so I asked my uncle right hey
how cause some of those murals say like
1979 1983 19 whatever bro and I was like
how was it back then and he stopped and
he was like it was cool it was cool back
then
it was different back then and then I
was like well what the [__] happened and
we broke it down bro that [__] shifted
when crack hit
like a lot of cities but like Los
Angeles specifically right East Los
Angeles specifically that's what you
know my uncle said that before that [__]
hit God you had full [__] um you know
doing a little heroin you know what I'm
saying down or [__] you know a little
acid a little [__] drink you know a
little but but when crack came bro
oh
like it just took the soul
it took the soul bro like because that
because I'm from the 90s but I grew up I
cannot started gang banging in the mid
90s bro like by that time we were not
teenagers were knocking each other down
for no respect no [__] party it was
pure murder you know that was it bro
that was it coming out of Junior High
blah blah blah blah blah 13 years old
what the [__] like this was it bro so
like it didn't like all I know was
different you know good or bad
everything had a [__] right but when
[__] when when women are
selling their children
right when [__] you know when when
these when these horrendous horrific
things that have never existed before
crack and the methamphetamine came in
you know that completely destroyed these
communities and that's what I entered do
you have any recollection of this
palpable shift or do you feel like you
were just born into it and that was the
world that you knew I was [__] born
into it and I was the [__]
world that I knew right why I remember
coming out of my apartments and even
screams in my [__] my [__] uh my
neighbor Largo from aravilla he's always
fighting his twenties and he's [__]
he has he's dragging his [__]
girlfriend in front of his kids and my
neighbor and his mom and he just beating
the dog [__] out of her right I'm like
13 14 and she's screaming and fighting
back you know what I'm saying like and
let's go before that right let's go
before that right because my home right
[__] hearing my mom get [__] beat
next door right like that's what it is
right you come up in [__] violence
you come up with like [__] what's
happening in the community
[__] the community what the [__] is
happening in your [__] home who is
beating your mom
[__] [__] just coming you
know it's that bro it's [__] you it's
for me bro if you want to know what the
[__] it is bro I'm an only child [__]
broken broken family bro my [__] dad
left and my here I am with my mom you
know and my mom's [__] up bro they're
all [__] up all [__] ghettos are
[__] up people that stay in that
mentality how they want to get out bro
but if you're there you're [__]
[__] up right so my mom [__] does
her thing right [__] it right
so here I am bro [__] two years old
[__] here you know what I'm saying
like [__] [__] mom loves more
[__] mom loves these
[__] more than me do you
remember how that felt as a child did
you feel that as a child
that's
why you hit the streets
that's why
you ain't you're supposed to [__]
love me you don't love me well [__] it
I'm gonna get this love baby [__] him up
this is what it is right those [__]
bro I bro [__] nice to be on those
streets [__] running so tough bro I
used to look forward to the days they
used to get busted because at least I
have a warm ass cop
at least I knew where I was gonna
[__] sleep at
I didn't you know what I'm saying like
Bro [__] it you know this is what it is
blown there ain't no [__] you're
crying for helping nobody coming
nobody comes bro
damn boy I wish somebody would have
[__] came nobody [__] came and
nobody came from all them [__] kids I
[__] that were housed in jail to me
bro I [__] almost institutionalized
when I was 13 years old so I was 25.
I was in a [__] cage till I was 13 12
25 not all together but you know what
I'm saying bro like yeah bro yeah that
shit's better than [__] than [__]
being on those streets and being in a
[__] home that ain't got no love bro
you give me an example of love that you
found from your homies or from people on
the street
[Music]
that's it and it's like terrible like
all of them falls off oh [__] is you
know all of them for all of my friends
for all of them were all [__] up and
here we are
[__] your dog at least we're gonna be
[__] up together right
you know [__] you and and that's it Paul
you [__] and inform this [__] Bond
bro that is unbreakable because at the
end of the day we're all a little
Warriors we're all little men that were
that were not mentored the right way
brought this fire in us has to be this
fire in us has to be [__] doubt with
you know but if there's nowhere to deal
with it you're gonna [__] you max out
you know in whatever way and that's it
bro you know it's it's it's that love
and then that's it that's it you can't
break that [__] right [__] are
dying out there Bro [__] my boy dies my
boys getting live my best friend got
life at 15.
Sammy has been also got life at 15. you
know so it was that you know blowing
yeah and then by the time you're 15 your
mind shifts for like [__]
see it you know I'm growing up in jail
my friends are getting live and
[__] are getting smoke Let's
Roll
let's roll let's [__] let's let's do
this [__] you know and then I could tell
you it wasn't until [__] I fought a
life sentence I I shot I shot a man in
East LA
and they're trying to give me 35 years
to life but I was 20 years old
and and that one got me that one [__]
me up how so that one shifted me because
like
you see all your life 19 years straight
[__] my son was like one and then you're
just like
it's just like [__] like this is what it
is you know he pulled me of a 35 year
life to [__] you have sentence on you
you know
and then
and then you just [__] just like
you're just thinking about life bro you
know that whole year I sat in the L.A
County Jail no I said no I didn't come
to jail for 11 months bro [__] 35 35
so I kept on hearing me playing my
[__] mind 35 years to life how old am
I gonna be
you know when the shifts your body
changes you yeah it's done you know and
[__] through the grace of God bro
[__] I remember the week before
two weeks before trial right
[__] because so what happened bro is
that
on pre-trial this fool said that I was
there but he said I didn't shoot him
so that was enough to send me the trial
but it wasn't enough to [__] to it
wasn't an open showcase right like we're
gonna have we're gonna we're gonna have
a trial right but it was enough to
convict me for gang Association they had
enough to convict me for gang of souls
were you pleading not guilty I [__]
play Not Guilty Bro [__] yeah I did bro
because so this is what happened bro
boom boom boom boom with a [__] 19
years old bro you wanna walk into the
night please all right [__] I'm with
the boys my son's like one bro and like
like in this style bro like those are my
friends right like I know that I need to
do good but like those are my friends
and like it just becomes one of those
nights we're drinking right we're
drinking and I and I don't and and I
don't give it wasn't the alcohols but it
influenced it of course right and that
kind of changed my whole view of alcohol
after right we're at the Commerce Casino
[__] all the boys are there and we
hit the hood
and [__] um and it's me and my
homeboy it's me and Demon [__] um
we're we're striking up
we're heading up the hood right
and I remember I had that burner on me
got in my back pocket I was crazy I
didn't have I didn't never used to carry
guns at that time right but for some
reason [__] it ever put the [__]
right here right
and then nah and and demon demon gets
off
spoon I post my position right boom I
got his back boom anybody comes I'm on
them right cops or whatever I'm giving
it to him right that's just and and for
the folks who don't know you're tagging
it yeah
can you just also just explain what so
what that's about because there's a lot
of [__] this is territorial Los
Angeles yeah you're not just drawing
pictures
striking up our our [__] territory to
let you [__] know where the
[__] you're at which is a very dangerous
Endeavor yeah with that so with with
that right but in my young mind I
already know what's up right homeboy
position homeboys on the [__] thing
I'm on the corner with the burner right
anybody comes cops come [__] fools
come boom I'm giving it to him
that's it so
I'm drinking
corner
and leave demon I [__] up I leave them
bro I have the murderer I leave is
and bro the big [__] the big
[__] he was like
and she's like I don't give a [__]
and [__] can I give it to him bam right
this was too big bro I can't but I'm
[__] on them right
boom boom he [__] Falls like I
remember him falling over me bro and
[__] demons in my rescue demons he's
on it right [__] he comes and boomers
are stomping this WOW boom boom boom
boom boom boom
get up
and I just boom I don't remember but I
just don't remember I [__] just
pulled off the burner bro and I just
thought boom boom
[__] one of them hit him bro one of
them hit him you saw it
nah I didn't even see it bro Boom the
the they scattered he starts he turns
and put it by the time he turned I
already had hit him
and [__] yeah and boom we're gone
we're gone bro we're gone we're gone and
[__] um I I um the next day they
already knew because the hurricane
so they go with a six-pack Boop
oh [__] I remember that morning bro
the next morning
I'm going I'm an electrician at the time
right and I'm getting ready for work and
I get a call
and it's my homeboy it's my boy termite
and he's like hey Bo what happened last
night
and he was like they're looking for you
bro
and boom I remember crying
remember I broke down remember I was
sitting in my mom's [__] stairs in
Santa Fe Springs
I hung up the phone and I [__] broke
and my life changed and my life changed
right there and that was it and that was
it they hit my grandma's house that
night I'm on a battle
and I went on the run I wanted to I want
to run the run I went on the Run of
Texas I went on my on one of the rental
see my dad you know
and then uh can you walk me through that
going on the run like what that like
what what what's your emotional state
right you're just like team demon
[__] we hit it demon [__] goals
they start hitting houses bro they start
hitting the homies houses looking for us
right I don't know if this one's dead or
what you know you're just not like
[__] looking for you right and you
[__] grandma calls you know [__]
they they come in like [__] SWAT team
goes to my grandma's house and my uncle
I remember my uncle was was living he
was there that night and then they he
seen him you know and he was like he's
not here but they were [__] he said
they were ready but the thing is crazy
because my mom used to work for
Montebello police when I was a little
boy so I think that's another reason why
they didn't just kick down the door you
know they knocked this
you know you know hey you know this is
you know Lourdes is [__] like it was
like that type of [__] like sergeants
that [__] a were just you know yeah
yeah bro and that was it [__] it was
gold time demon went to the desert and I
went to Texas bro and and it was just
like let's see how this [__] unfolds you
know
and um I was sitting in El Paso my dad
and he was like you could go to Mexico
son you had a house you know
and I was like [__] I remember sitting
there like in his yard and like my son
was one
you gave me my son was one two bro like
it was that type of [__] like I remember
when I left my son like [__] I might
never see him he was like he didn't know
he was like you don't want to stop bro
you're just like [__] like
and then I hear that
I hear that that dude survived and that
he's not gonna snitch
and that the reason why he's not going
to snitch is because he wants his run
back
and I was like oh
I'll [__] deal with that right I'll
[__] here I'll [__] take one right
[__] whatever we'll see each other
I'll take that [__]
and instead of going to Mexico I trust
that bro and I was like [__] it let's go
I turn myself in WoW
I cheer myself in bro I turn myself in
at the Montevallo police station can you
can you walk me through that choice and
yeah
so [__] we go bro
and um and it was like yeah I didn't
want to be like I knew what that word
like that's it bro On The Run you're
never coming back I knew I knew you know
and then I was like I didn't kill this
[__] I know they're gonna try to
wash me up but I didn't kill his ass you
know so [__] it let's face the music
baby because it was that like [__] it
like here this is my life is right let's
face this [__] I wanted the county jail
on my 18th birthday so I already had
[__] you know County Jail experience
and what they say about the LA County
Jail that if you could survive the LA
County Jail
you could survive any [__] prison in
the United do you agree with that [__]
yeah
[__] yeah bro it's it's there's yeah bro
it's dark the dungeons bro right so I
don't know if this is gonna make it or
what but I don't have no money bro I'm
[__] so the only way to make money in
the county jail is to sell [__] dope
right I need you know like if they know
if I don't got no money my mommy gonna
send me [__] my girl ain't gonna send me
[__] so yeah bro that [__] that that
starts off my my um
the trials in both yeah and then 11
months in the county jail and then so
the week before brother the week before
I go to trial
um the judge she tells me um Mr cabrab
I know you want to go to trial but we
have an offer for 13 years
and [__] she didn't even [__] wait
for me to reply but she was like the way
you're looking at me right now I know
you're not gonna take it and I was like
nah I ain't gonna take it because the
max for the gang allegations was 10
years
murder was 25 so I knew I could be the
attempted murder and if they they could
only match me out for 10 years you knew
he wasn't gonna snitch
bro on the [__] pre-trial right so
it's the [__] big thing he comes bro
he comes
and he gets up there bro and it's the
big question is Richard cabal is the man
that shot you right here is he here
today
and looked at me and he said no
he said no bro you know so it was like
but they were still trying to push this
[__] you get me what do you think his
motivation was for saying because he
wanted
himself yeah yeah cool cool so I knew
you have any idea at this point do you
know who this guy is do you know what
his do you know anything about him have
you asked about him no do you care about
I mean you know like whatever like like
real [__] like
when you're on the streets bro
and you're active [__] happens
you know and if and I and like even [__]
that's happened to me [__] that's
happened to my mind you know like it
comes with the you know it comes with
the territory you know and I'm not
saying that like I'm not
it's that bro you know what I'm saying
like like it is what it is bro you know
and I don't have an issue with it but if
you had an issue that's kind of on him
you know I wouldn't do it you know I'm
sorry that that [__] happened like that
bro like straight up was it would I do
that [__] again faulknown right was it
the right reason Fox wasn't the right
reason right but it's done bro you know
but this is what happens when you're in
the [__] you know I understand that
and I don't but I don't know if he has
the same understanding of that
so yeah that's kind of that's kind of
how it wrapped up you know um yeah the
day before trial
they offered me five years
the day before trial they offered me
Five Years bro it's very it's jury
selection they offered me five years and
so I get two years for the um gray
bodily injury they slap another two
years for the [__] gang Association
and they put one more year because I got
busted with weed in the alley County
jail oh really
is that true really how and how did you
get how did you get busted
bro [__] with bro we can't stop this
[__] bro
so what happened right so what was crazy
as [__] bro [__] crazy as [__] but
we're at East Max but I'm not bro
[__] Sheriff gets popped for bringing
dope to the homies I'm not involved bro
I'm just I'm not even politicking bro
I'm just I'm reaping the rewards right
yeah yeah I'm a southerner bro I'm gonna
get tripped off bro I'm a southerner
right so [__] bro we have so much
meth in the [__] dorm bro East Max
[__] you're This Way East but
we have so much math bro we literally
have [__] Street knives
we have Street knives in jail
like it's scary bro but I'm like my team
has it so I'm like we're good yeah yeah
you [__] just gotta worry about
it right yeah yeah so bro so everybody
bro it's crazy bro look like bro there's
so much [__] heroin and so much bro
I'm walking down and they're just like
there's little 19 year olds and
everybody's fighting life that's the
thing about this time but it's so crazy
because the guys that are fighting life
LA County Jail Pro from 18 to 25 that's
the majority there's hundreds of us
blacks blacks and Mexicans bro all
fighting life bro and think I didn't
kill nobody right I didn't kill nobody
bro
you get what I'm saying I'm not saying
that my my crime isn't worth [__]
justice but like bro we're all [__]
so anyhow bro
[__] this fool gets high
the night before
and he [__] and he's the thing about
methamphetamine it [__] you up bro but
in jail we say your skeletons come out
right because all those secrets that you
have they come out bro and in the
gangster world we don't play for [__]
you can't so if there's little things in
the math boom bro this [__] run
you [__] we're in a 130 it's a dorm
of 130 people right he [__] runs ah
they're gonna kill me some crazy [__]
right and then everybody knows by this
time like sometimes it happens oh
there's another one there he goes right
and he [__] starts
some crazy [__] Bro right [__] so uh
whatever right
so we go to sleep right but in the
morning like all everybody that's
running their like we gotta just be on
our [__] right hey so I'm up early we
call it the guy all right hey bro can
you get the morning shift yeah I got the
morning shift bro I'm up at five in the
morning doing my burpees and um so he's
like can you hold this [__] I'm like bro
I got that [__] phone he gives me the
knife and he gives me the weed right
um and I was like yeah go ahead do your
thing bro I got this [__] right
[__] and sure enough bro like I
remember
like an hour and then you just hear them
when the boys come the boys come
boom get the [__] boom [__] I'm like oh
[__] yeah yeah I'm running I'm running
through my soul I got him ready to go so
what does that mean
that all right these things are about to
go up your ass right so you got to make
sure the shit's lubricated right if the
[__] goes down so I got them wrapped up
I got them wrapped up in the [__]
fingers all that and then I got him in
another bag in the lotion in the lotion
bag
right so they're still they're sitting
in your lotion bag they're sitting in
the lotion bag right wrapped up ready to
go
they [__] come on
[__] I'm running to my [__] bed bro I
I I I make my my bunk entrance pool
because I I gotta I gotta [__] drop
low right and [__] I was like I got
the weed and I got the knife which one
is more important
got me the knife
exactly yeah it's tonight right yeah
[__] oh he's got me with a big Bertha
bro whatever these are the Bros these
you know those [__] those [__]
those things kill people bro I don't
know if they're the the spray ones bro
but he's coming bro and he's like
you get the [__] down and there's only a
few of us and he knows it's a race
between him and you getting it I mean
that's that's something this [__] bro
I'm like and I'm down bro I'm [__]
squatting I'm like I get it and I'm
trying to find it you're trying to find
the spot right you gotta find it and
then he's coming like get the [__] down
he's like get on your bunks and I was
like [__] you yeah and I find the spot
and I just go
[__] bro
making sure that you got the right end
going up first you ain't forget that get
in there bro he [__] he comes down he
knows bro he knows because by the time
he catches me I'm I have my because I
come from the front I'm taking on my
hand and he's like
he's like here's something in disaster
[Laughter]
he stepped it in his ass he [__] and
yeah I did right but he [__] takes me
to the game and he was like yes I'm
first one bro I'm the first yeah boom I
can slammed on the gate I'm like [__]
you that [__] are you ain't getting that
[__] you ain't getting that [__]
[__] and the more I'm walking
that's what's going on right right and
[__] but I have the weed and then
[__] boom boom boom
but that's the only reason why that
saved me that I got caught for the weed
instead of the knife well
so that's how I got the extra year yeah
but when you get that sentence and then
they and then I go to court right now
I'm in Santa Clarita Court I'm like what
the [__] am I doing in Santa Clarita
right Richard got court [__] Santa
Clarita from La [__] yeah so I
go and then they're like all right
[__]
what's the charge I don't even know the
charge oh [__] having controlled
substance in a [__] jail facility
whatever yeah
um do you plea bargain uh uh what do
they give me uh one year I'm like
[__] I'm fighting 35 throw that [__]
off baby you come down with that
five-year sentence ultimately what's
your mindset around that I mean is that
like oh like [__] well [__] I'm at CCB
Court bro CCB court is Charles Manson
[__] the Menendez everybody came out
I'm in the legend alley the [__] all
the Hollywood I'm there bro you know and
and everybody knows that chord from the
outside from all these big cases but I'm
going from the inside from The Dungeons
where there's thousands of Us coming
from the Alley County Jail bus
[__] just seeing all of them were all
young going to trial and they'll come
back gave me 50 years dog gave me 80.
gave me 30. I took a deal for 25 homie
at least I'm getting out you know so
this becomes your Norm bro your Norm
your norm and I'll tell you I remember
it bro
I was so I didn't even want to tell
anybody how much time I got yeah
I felt I felt guilty you know I felt I
felt guilty because these fools I mean I
remember my he was um
it was I think stomper from vienne right
but he was from the from Another Side he
was 19 but I remember him [__] we
were being these um these metal these
cages right the holding tanks and like
we would be sleeping on [__] on each
other sometimes I remember that he he
stepped on my uh he used my my thigh as
his pillow right and [__] remember 19
broke in 55 years you know and so it was
that bro when I got those five years I
was just grateful bro I was blessed I
knew that because I could have easily
easily got those 35 when you saw
these young men you know guys coming up
to you and saying hey man I got you know
50 years I got 30 years you know and did
you see the the fear and the pain behind
it for sure I remember the first time
that that fear hit me on that
that reality hit me I was I was um in
the alley County jail and you know I
think it was on that time right but it
was all during the same time right 18 to
20 I was in and out and I was sitting in
the gang module right I just got
transferred to the gang module and it
was a one-man sow
and I remember just like like looking in
in this dark place right the walls just
in front of you the lights are dim and I
remember people are getting [__] stop
I remember this this dude walked by my
cell and he was no good right and my
neighbor [__] stuck he was actually
he was at the sheriff walking was crazy
bro the sheriff was walking on from
court and [__] my neighbor stuck his
[__] arm off the thing and sliced his
face with a razor
when you say he was no good can you
explain what that means so in our
political system of um of of
prison right with with our cultures the
whites the the blacks we all have our
own um politics right our own
organizations and so with within ours
within the southerners of LA County
um he was no good in that aspect like
meaning that he was part of us but he
was no longer a part of us right and
once you are no longer a part of us and
if you're in our presence we we um we
are are obligated or we are rightful to
engage in violence you know and whatever
whatever your
um I guess whatever you have done will
matter on how the end result will happen
so it could go all the way from a
beating all the way to a killing right
but that just determines on on the on
the case itself and can you explain
because I think that there's probably a
lot of people questions questions
and this understanding of like when
you're in that situation can you can you
explain the walls I mean literally that
around you the rules like politics
people understand the politics right
because the politics don't are not set
in prisons the politics come from your
neighborhood
right so whatever you do inside will
affect you outside
will affect you inside right I know
exactly and affect the people that you
love if the people that you love are
associated with which most likely
they're going to be because it's your
family right and this is generational
trauma that we're talking about so your
[__] families more than likely going
to be involved in the gangs so that
that's that's when you're stuck between
a [__] hard place and a rock that's
kind of what it is but looking back you
understand this where you understand
where it's all coming from and you have
the ability to not hide from the
shopping okay you can go right back into
that world emotionally right even though
all you're trying to do out in the world
now is positivity right and I find that
uh I find that beyond beautiful bro can
you look back at your upbringing and can
you think of an example of somebody in
your life
was there anybody who was trying to lead
you into a path that you would want to
lead a youngster into now was there
anybody looking out for you can you
think of anybody uh did you have that or
do you feel like you don't want there
was good people in my family you gave me
but like I don't think they really had a
true understanding of what this what
systemic oppression is for sure but it's
not really about being a good person I
mean there are plenty of good the
situation you're in jail doesn't matter
whether you're good or bad once you're
there yeah you're there dude and it's
about like cutting that like it's not
really your choice at that point and I
would love for you to explain that right
but I also like I know it's a lot of
questions no no no you're good we're
here but but like because I really
believe and I know folks that really
just didn't have that yeah there was
really yeah like that that's mindful
that's really and like I said you know
we were crying for help but nobody came
you know father Greg you know father
Greg changed my life father Greg Boyle
of Homeboy Industries if it wasn't for
that man I wouldn't be here today right
and so if people that don't know know
who father Greg is Father Greg operates
the biggest gang non-profit organization
in the [__] world right it's been
around for almost 35 years he has worked
with just gang members all his life he
has buried close to maybe 250 to this
day as we speak
continuously burying you get what I'm
saying continuously engaged right and
when he came into my life
and showed me love
showed me [__] love because love gets
[__] thrown around too much right
when he just like what you're doing
right now bro just looking at me in the
eyes and [__] listening to me bro
listening no one listening bro bro
everybody's crying for help all these
kids are crying for help but nobody's
[__] listening and when he did that
it was [__] and it [__] me up it
took so long to truly understand that a
person could just genuinely just want to
hear me do you care about me
if that would have happened before in a
real way not coming in because a lot of
people get the [__] [__] up you can't
come in one day and think that the child
is going to be okay give them some good
words
if you gotta if you want to be committed
to this [__] to to the help you have
to be committed bro you know and give
yourself Seasons no one's saying don't
burn out because I've seen that [__] too
in this work but I do this work I I'm in
the hood because I come from the hood
but it's it's you have to be willing to
[__] go you know and yes but no bro
if if someone would have been there I
think I would have because when it came
I did listen exactly can you tell me
about how you how he came into your life
so I get out of prison right and and for
those that are in Los Angeles all gangs
bro if you're from a gang you have a
connection to Homeboy Industries that
has been around black Mexican
Salvadorian Korean whatever gang you're
in Los Angeles real gangs right
that you have a direct connection
somehow someone came in and sure enough
when I came out of prison and it's that
right like you you're a gang member you
have I'm tatted up I'm [__] on parole
like who's gonna then there's that [__]
right you want to talk about [__]
like bro here we go 200 dollars I made
this [__] [__] happen with 200 I'm
sitting across you they [__] gave me
200 I make this [__] happen that's right
that's what it is but you don't have no
understanding of like [__] where to
go right Homeboy Industries bro yeah
homeboys okay so before you even get
that you get the 200 now you're out
you've done what you've done in we
haven't even talked about prison but you
get you you get out yeah
and and I think that that's another
thing people don't understand I mean bro
No One's Gonna hire you where do you go
like what like like talk about that
feeling talk about that first week out
talk about boy and and it's this you
know my mom picks me up
and she picks you up and you know it but
it's the same [__] you're going back to
the same [__] that you came out of
and it's it's that you know you you have
my son's five
I haven't seen him he doesn't know me
hmm
you know like [__] you're just like all
right [__] like like here I am right
here I am but I knew one thing that I
was clear-headed right
and um what do you mean I was I was
clear I was more clear than I have ever
been right like I I've seen life bro
like I remember the first stabbing that
I seen and I am with prison bro like I'm
on the yard for like a [__] week
boom are down thousands or thou over a
thousand and I look I'm like 21 when I
hit the yard bro I'm a young kid still
I'm damn [__] you know small but I
mean
and I just see these [__] they're
like our age bro just
just yard down and these fools ain't
stopping
ducking
boom blow that fool I don't know if he
died or what and then you find out that
he was a [__] I think he was a child
molester or a rapist either or both
and this is how we're dealing with it
right
and you have to [__] you have to just
acknowledge it right you gotta
understanding it all bro but seeing what
the truth is you know and yeah bro that
[__] changed me bro that [__] [__]
prison changed me bro prison [__]
seeing homies just [__]
just overdosing on heroin Under the
Stairs type of [__] right just seeing
[__] your own turning the thing about
I did time in the South there you go
doing time in the South and doing time
in the north is completely different
because in the south
there's thousands of us bro we don't
have to be going at it with the Nortenos
up there right so it's I think it's a
setting like this when you're amongst
when all of you are there
and you don't have nobody to turn on to
turn two you turn on each other
and that's what was happening and I knew
at that moment that I didn't know what
the [__] I wanted to do but I knew I
didn't want to do that you know and I
knew and at that time my crime people it
was crazy because my crying demon
he's the only I took the rap nothing
happened to demon bro it was my but at
the end of it you know that's how I was
bro [__] but they thought that they
had me they're like [__] it we're going
to give him life we don't need demon
right
demon [__] gets out demon gets
paralyzed wow how so got shot bro and I
would have been there you get what I'm
saying so like these things are [__]
happening in my life these three years
where were you when you found that out
an Ironwood block at the letter they're
like [__] sure enough but but I would
have been there those are my boys how
long is that immediate do you make that
connection immediately no immediately
immediately gratitude what's the it's
gratitude but because I love these
[__] it's also like [__] dog
like would that have happened you know
could I have saved them you know just
part of you say [__] man you don't need
to be doing this you're out there you
don't need to be doing this or do you
not you're not there yet at that time
bro because even right now bro I cherish
every single relationship I had on my
name you know and I'm still in contact
with my boys that's so it's like yeah I
know now I know what positions I should
you know because it's that bro I'm like
bro I don't live like that no more right
so if you're living like that that
shit's gonna happen to you right I'm not
living like that but if I'm there with
you you know but yeah bro it's these
things that that just
[__] oh my [__] remember my best
friend
Sammy has been also like a life yeah I'm
I'm like eight months out bro on a new
bus so every time a new bus comes hits
the yard well homies are here right
making sure whoever's and we've got a
couple Eastsiders so in prison it's very
specific like that it's not just about
the county it's specific of your area of
course East Side Right where's the
Eastside car at right we got a couple
new Eastsiders
and but I'm sure enough
wow just came down from Pelican Bay wow
either came down from the bay or from
Folsom but he has already been down 15
years
so it's like yeah bro and [__] yeah
it was it was it was a trip because he
he told me how that [__] went down
and and he and he pretty much tells me
like if if things would have been
different he wouldn't he wasn't supposed
to get life bro
Sammy wasn't supposed to get life
that's that's pretty much what happened
bro
so what do you mean Sammy was a supposed
to get life because so Sammy so what
happened on the case is that
he shot he shot this fool
n and his mom was in front of him right
it was a whole thing right homeboy had a
gun though too
but when the whole ordeal happened
another gang member comes and takes the
gun
so the self-defense [__] is gone gone
life
do you think in your experience man and
and this is something you know you asked
me in the beginning like why you know
what was this show about like why do I
do this in the first place there are so
many people bro who just get
just get thrown thrown in and and and
and and and so many people's lives just
that's it and you know there's there's
people
um who engage there's people who who who
have who have done things that are
ashamed of they're people who have uh
not followed the rules and and and have
I I should have learned lessons and kept
on going but they still they get this
opportunity they get this chance they
get
when I was young I got in a lot of
trouble but I had people around me to
look out for me and I've always uh
there's been a great deal of Shame about
how uh the disparity in in in in
fairness and the the real shakes that we
get in this [__] world just this
notion of so many people like your
friend Sammy that had they had a legal
team had they had this like so many
people their lives are just thrown away
and they're that the hope is just
[__] pulled out yeah yeah what
percentage of people are there not that
they didn't make mistakes but everybody
it's not Justice yeah talk about Justice
talk about that I mean I mean everybody
bro every uh you know I I it's then you
got those cases right righteous you know
righteous intentional murders right that
all that you know like that that's what
it is right like yeah like you know you
have to face your consequences for that
type of [__] but like yeah bro that
that's the overall like that everybody I
[__] know right like no one got a
fair chance like that I believe because
no one was papered up bro you have to
have a [__] proper legal defense you
need to have a little bit [__] cash
in your pocket bro the hood ain't got no
cash in their pocket so you're [__]
dealing with a public defender I'm
grateful my state appointed I want to
find that [__] I can't find this
one I stayed a point in bro yeah
I'm trying Hey so but bro I was blessed
because mine was a high profile case
that I was that I was able to get a
state appointed you get what I'm sold so
yeah bro it's that yeah I believe that
that's you know when you look at Sammy
and you look at look look at the
situation you're in I mean when you hear
that when you hear that that's the
situation I mean what do you does any
part of you I mean you do you recognize
that Injustice does that make you want
to take ownership of the the opportunity
that you feel like you have for sure and
that's why I do what I do bro that's why
AI people that don't know about that
like they trip out that I'm like bro I
never left you get what I'm saying like
how I I have to bro you know I I'm I I'm
that person you know we are that people
right whoever yeah bro yeah yeah it's a
certain obligation but I understand that
this is it it heals you get what I'm
saying like I've done it all brought it
I thought I was a savior type of [__]
right why me why me right [__] like
everybody bro but it doesn't work like
that either bro you could walk to the
[__] horse you know the horse the
water but you can't you know can't have
them drink it don't drink it yeah type
of [__] you know so it it's also that
you know but it's it's deep Bro and it's
systemic you know and and it's in the
[__] it's in it's in these
communities like that and it's a hard
thing to [__] come back but I believe
what I am doing is is definitely you
know
talk again about uh father Boyle is it
father father Greg yeah father great
yeah father Boyle yeah yeah
um you know I I left maybe like 10 years
ago um that's where acting came bro
that's where my first acting job came
out of you know Southland
um they were looking for some real
homies you know and they came and that's
a trip too because like I remember
during that season 10 of us went to
Warner Brothers Studio and
and we got the part but I was the only
one that knew that there was more to it
right because we talk about these
communities bro acting things that are
normal to us in this bro there's no
sense there's there's no connection to
it bro so I knew that there was like a
professional training I knew it I had no
direct connection to it bro but at that
time I was in the bakery right and I was
at I was gonna be a masturbate or not
masturbate whatever the [__] right a
culinary chef of Bakery whatever they
they were paying for me to go to school
right that's the thing about homeboys so
whatever your thing is it's not just
about a job right they help you in
whatever you think your [__] is you know
what I'm saying you want to be a [__]
a DP you want to be a cameraman will
help you to [__] it's not just about
the job bro but where are you where are
you at this point mentally have you
decided are you done with the gangs are
you done with are you are you saying
like hey look I'm not gonna live a life
of crime anymore I come out and I come
out respected now
I just did a bid on an attempt to murder
for the hood you get me yeah so like I'm
coming back I'm still engaged but I'm
coming back different how so
when you come out of a prison mentality
with these and you're still involved in
in the neighborhood you come not
willingly or unwillingly you're an
enforcer now right you're like hey this
[__] ain't not you know you've been for
you ain't playing like and at that time
I'm getting into mad fights with the
homies right bam like because that that
that's it like these last three years I
have been trained and [__] we just
been fighting rioting stabbing fighting
writing stabbing that's it baby that's
it so me [__] me taking off on you
ain't [__] to me right now right so yeah
bro I come out and and I'm kind of that
you know like but not enforcing it but
I'm a presence right I'm a presence and
I'm a presence for my little homies and
I'm a presence for the older homies but
I knew that I I needed to do something
different and that was at homeboys bro
that was that was father grade right
there I I hate to Harbor broken when you
say that like you knew you needed to do
something different right was there
something specific that happened that
made you know and what different explain
the difference you know what my my son I
think the big them the game changer was
my son bro I remember that Journey right
going to Palmdale and I don't have no
money you know I have to take the train
take the train to Palmdale I can find to
find his apartment his mind he's knowing
it you know his mom left them you know
we we we met his mom she kind of did him
dirty like that you know and I'm not
gonna throw her under the bus but she
ain't around at that time and his
grandma's there right I knock on the
door and um and he's in the room
and then she she was like Adrian there's
someone here to see you
and that's a little [__] little white
complexity little boy comes out you know
he [__] little [__] up I was like
yeah silver teeth at that time [__] I'm
like damn my boy what happened and he
has a little GI Joe
I remember you [__] like he just
hands it to me you know and she's like
that's your dad
and then it was out bro you know you're
just like [__] like I changed your dog
you're like [__] like like my dad wasn't
there and like
and like here you are like you know you
love me and [__] but like I gotta I
gotta fix this [__] son you know you
know I'm sorry exciting you know I don't
know but you just feel these emotions
you know and I think that was the
[__] right there bro like and I
didn't know I I didn't know what I was
gonna do but I knew that I had to
[__] be there you know I know because
my dad left bro my dad left the [__]
Texas you know like and and not having
your dad makes a [__] difference bro
you know not having your mom makes a
[__] difference when not having your
[__] dad makes a difference bro when
you say you knew then that you needed to
be there what would it be there mean
what did that encompass and like my mind
could only grasp what it could grasp at
that time I knew that I couldn't leave
you
but I wasn't going to leave you that I
was gonna show up
that's it that's all I'm gonna take you
to McDonald's all I got is enough money
for McDonald's my son but I'm gonna take
you
if we overthink this [__]
[__] Cloud [__] psychology therapy
just [__] be there for your children
you dumb [__]
be there love them listen
it's not complicated homie right
see it bro that's all I did bro that's
all I did he [__] is and then I
didn't stop bro [__] was it not bro
his mom [__] him up you know and I
[__] boom [__] I'm gonna be right
here son and that little boy's the boy
that I met and oh boy he's a little you
know what's going on that boy what the
you know and I tell you what man that
you know because we you know we just you
you know had this beautiful you know
artistic experience man where you you
know and and and I met I met that boy
you know and that's a love boy man he
loves his dad and that that's that's
that's a solid young man you did your
job bro how you started in all right
like that night bro like [__] me and
you made magic that night bro like a
whole team you know
and like [__] from my son to see us
you know like you know like him come and
experience that [__] premium theater
that premium gift of audience and
[__] performers you know
and that night his [__] best friend
his niece died
that night bro
put his cousin his best friend his
[__] dog Marissa bro he [__] died
that night bro
and [__] like
and it was [__] I walked in that
room bro and he and Jose was with them
boy and I was age like we've been up on
April
and he was like Maurice Marissa died
last night that
and he was just like [__]
and it was just like boom bro like that
was the one that took him he never had
nobody that close that you know like
that was his [__] best friend bro and
JuJu in like
and it was like oh this is gold time
this is gold time not all those all
those trips everything this is gold time
what are you gonna do rich you know how
to be there for him I had to love him I
had to just that was my niece Paul
Marissa my niece you know I [__] seen
her like that
but I was like it's not that time for
you to [__] mourn don't be it's not
that time for you to cry right now Rich
you got to be there for him
that's what it was bro you know so yeah
that's it bro you know it keeps on
evolving the being but I think it's
still being at the end of the day being
listening comforting
that's what I try to do
so you have that uh experience with the
little man with the GI Joe and uh you
decide you're gonna be there so if you
be there that means you can't
you know you can't [__] up no more right
the people like life is always gonna
[__] it's gonna come with it right
our life is always going to throw me
struggles right bro but but life is
always going to present where where you
could get out but I needed to [__]
just stay committed right stay committed
to [__] growing and evolving and not
wanting bro I don't want negative [__]
you know at the end of it bro hood [__]
is negative it's a low frequency bro and
and it's it's [__] that are
that aren't some survival [__] you get
them so I knew that I didn't want that
and as long as I refocus my energy the
world kept on opening up to me opening
up to the [__] Universe I don't know
what it is universe but whatever the
[__] you want show me and I'll [__]
and and I'll run with it that's it bro
talk to me about you it's refocusing
your energy that's
all it is did it take you know getting
into being an artist [__] yeah can you
remember the first day you tapped into
something
gergis [__]
what the [__] was it den of Thieves
Flaco bro yeah bro bro that when I
tapped into the art right because I
believe as an artist right that it's an
it's a way to [__] um get these get
these emotions out [__] understand
these emotions in a real way right and
and when I read that [__] monologue
from Flaco and for people that I don't
know that monologue it's it pretty much
it's him explain so the play is you
remember that place of course [__] it
right it's the scene we're [__]
they're all who why shouldn't I die why
should you why shouldn't I die and why
should you die type of [__] right and
everybody's giving their [__]
monologue of life and so Flaco goes and
he starts off but you think Flaco's a
badass [__] right you just think
he's a [__] dick and in that
monologue he explains if you would have
grew up like me
and if you would have [__] faced and
had to endure what would you do type of
[__] you know like I remember the second
time I just I did it I remember I went
in
boom
I [__] I read it my acting culture is
like
let's do that [__] one more time rich
but he knew he knew it was coming bro he
knew it was coming and I remember I sat
on that chair and I hit that [__]
monologue bro
and I [__] broke yeah
I remember I cried for I cried but I
cried I cried but when I [__] in that
[__] on that stage pool
and I wanna buy and something told me
like because when you when it has a man
born in these communities when you cry
you try to shut that [__] down and like
I remember that there didn't he was like
here it is Rich like just let it go
Let It Go rich and [__] [__] yeah
and you're just there you're gone you're
gone
you're gone in the spirit world right
that's right
real [__] don't know that [__]
when you're in it bro we're in the
spirit world we're no longer here
and I remember just the full turn out
the lights and talking people are
[__] just you know it changes you bro
it changes everybody when you experience
something that was [__] real you know
and like that was it though yeah yeah
how was it I was like [__] it you know I
didn't know I didn't know how to
understand the process I was all [__]
up but I knew something [__] was
released
and I was it bro I said I don't know
what this acting shit's gonna be but if
I could keep on exercising this [__]
yeah and keep on making money in this
career that's good enough for me [__]
yeah for somebody out there who's lost
and is looking for something
as much energy you got enough to search
on Tick Tock and Instagram [__]
get your [__] energy and search over
there yeah yeah it's an optional yeah
bro like
have an you have Bo you have a [__]
you know you have a choice these days
everybody everybody has a [__] Choice
that's right right no one [__] forced
you to [__] stay in the [__]
theater and do all that [__] I remember
I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you so I wasn't
I was in Ironwood State Prison right and
so they make you do these pre-release
class right and they [__] they tell
you about how to spend your money and
stupid [__] right okay with the governor
who gives a [__] what the governor says
I'm here cause I'm [__] yeah
wow
[Music]
wow and and I like bro like bro like
you're seeing TV you're seeing culinary
you're seeing machete like but you don't
there's no stories Danny doesn't have us
you know if you unless you're unless you
have access to [__] here like hear a
story you don't know bro and I don't
know and then I hear like he was in San
Quentin he like like I was like oh this
fool was me you know like that clitor
and and it was that like
and I remember suspect entertainment had
came out maximum magazine I don't know
remember this maximum Mac maximum
magazine had put out this article on
suspect entertainment that were a group
of homies during that time and they were
like on training day when David Ayer was
better they're not they're not terrible
they were all background homies and that
and the Danny Trejo during that time
right before coming out of prison it
sparked that see through wow straight up
wow straight the [__] up so when
Southwest came bro
I was already going I was like I [__]
yeah it was like [__] Danny could do
it you got these fools doing it like it
was that but most [__] do they
get into this thing and they come out
here to LA and they're like yo a casting
call like hey I want to be on TV hey but
but the fact that you went in and you're
[__] [__] with good like you're
you're in acting class you're going into
theater I mean the first time you and I
met the first time you and I met were
down in Shreveport Louisiana talking
about theater talking about theater man
and like you were just some dude like
who is this cat you like came up to me
like yo bro I mean you were just in that
one little scene with me and I I'll
never forget I was telling my wife about
it this morning I'm like baby he like
came up to me this like young caddies
all tatted up and I'm like doing my
thing he's like yo bro go as hard as you
[__] want to go this is that kind of
[__] dude and he's like and then
like we did it once and you're like no
dude like for real come hard I'm like
this dudes about that life and I
remember I like choked you up against
somebody and you were like going back at
me like yo I [__] with this dude and you
said like what do I do like what like
what do you think and I was like theater
bro
you did that bro like that's so rare
it's like this though like when I when I
was in the [__] bro I maxed out I always
want like bro the gang module what
people don't know about the gang module
now like County Jail it's where they put
like the [__] like the worst of the
the the worst of the worst the
high-ranking southern offenders right
bro like you're and like in there bro
it's separate like your militant bro you
but like it was crazy because I wanted
to be there
in my mind I always want to [__] max
out where's the max in this baby I'm
gonna find that [__] and all then I'll
make my [__] then I could tell you
what this [__] is but until you if you
don't go hard you're never gonna find
out that was the main thing bro I knew I
had to max out I had a you got a good
energy right I had to stop the bakery
[__] or you want to be an actor Richard
stop that [__] because you can't you're
gonna have you're gonna be half half
good right it was really that bro just
gotta go all the way because if not
you're not gonna see the results that's
right and that was it bro I seen all the
results I went all out in the gang world
bro I seen it I [__] got like I was
gonna get life right and for and when
the acting came in I was like and it was
that what people don't know bro like
you're from the East Coast I'm from the
West Coast bro training as an actor well
I don't know where you train that but
bro it's different it's different
[__] different bro [__] come
out here and you're just like what this
is acting like everybody looks pretty as
[__] you guys all you fools are pretty
audition class and like how to do a
commercial model well that's what I'm
saying I have so much respect for that
but but but see for me think about this
is why I broke Because by the time I
came into acting Pro I was an outsider
already bro I was already blasted up
right I knew all the [__] all the
other [__] I couldn't but when I had
kids let's not forget that bro [__] [__]
what everybody's talking about bro
[__] I had to make this shop
this [__] happen what one now four kids
I've always had kids during this whole
time right so this couldn't be my hobby
type of [__] bro I needed to make this
[__] work bro and the only way I was
gonna make this [__] work and understand
if this [__] was gonna work as if I
maxed out fast how did you figure out
how did you know that maxing out meant
getting on stage doing a one-man show
reading plays getting into theater how
did you not how did you just would so
many people make the mistake that maxing
out is if I'm not actively trying to get
on TV if I'm not actively trying to get
an agent yeah
on that opportunity comes and when [__]
hits the fan dog all that other [__]
doesn't give [__] when you're in the
presence of you homie and I'm gonna tell
you one more
the first time I [__] felt that was
when Mel Gibson on blood father bro and
Mal was not [__] playing homie and if
I wasn't ready to [__] match that
straight up homie yeah bring it yeah
is your Instagram gonna help you with
that
straight up right and boom you're done
homie you're done you're one opportunity
just came and if you're [__] let this
[__] it's gone baby
type of [__] right nah you ain't gonna
do that [__] to me you ain't doing that
[__] to me baby now I don't give a [__]
Mal bring that [__] let's go let's go
yeah yeah
but it was that type of [__] because he
comes to [__] engaged when you come
with the big wigs dog and like bro like
I was talking with my girl Pro like I
was blessed dog like within the first
year and a half bro like I'm [__] I'm
a really Scott Park I'm a [__] fast
spender and all the influence on the
counselor type of [__] dog like and it
was just like you bet broke
if I didn't do that
when the monologue
of Really Scott came
and you're you got that opportunity
homie
and you're not able to deliver that [__]
that's right and for me that was it bro
like and for me like yeah [__]
I handled that monologue and well Really
Scott in that time you know what I'm
saying I'm not like life has happened
but it's not bro if I wasn't ready for
that opportunity I've seen that [__]
I've seen actors fumble on there and
they look like [__] they look stupid
as [__] but you have an opportunity
homie and you [__] you did a few more
push-ups instead of reading your lines
we did a few more push-ups you stupid
[__] instead of knowing your
lines
but you
it's coming at me you said you said you
read that there's so many people now
that like well I can get this
opportunity like you know I come from
the gang world I come from this world I
came from the military world so I can
play military but like you somehow had
the presence of me it was like this bro
like bro you [__] look at them bro
you come who the [__] did you like what
did they do who did you like what did
they do who did you like what did they
do that's right Meryl Streep Pacino was
right on from that for scar you know all
that [__] though whatever bro whoever
the [__] you're got your go-to was right
what who are your favorites and what did
they do and when you go back to that era
right all of them came from the theater
every single one
so why should it be any different that's
right and you have this understanding
what did you read it's Donna's flasky
Meisner [__] oh let's go give me all
that [__] give me all that [__] I'm
gonna Mac that's how you're gonna max
out I want everything I want to
understand every nook and [__] cranny
of this for you because you ain't gonna
get over on me that's right
that's right and if you approach life
like that how can you get [__] [__]
you know what I'm saying that's right
that's that that's me that's me brother
that's right in your words how do you
explain sort of the difference between
theater and and and film and television
you know like what what does that mean
it's respect mediums yeah but as a as a
performer
there is nothing like the theater there
is nothing that brings Greater Joy To My
Soul than the [__] theater because
it's not about me it's about them it's
about us it's about the audience and
it's about you know it's it's a it
becomes this this Eunice this ecosystem
of energy in the theater Pro and that is
something that you cannot capture on
film and television and and yeah until
this until my dying day I believe as
long as I'm acting I will forever want
to be in the theater yeah amen amen can
you tell me uh just if you could uh you
talked about it a little bit but but
again I really um I was really taken
with your your relationship with your
with with your son man I I I I love
spending time with him and what uh you
know I hate that he he had that tragedy
you know later on in that night
um but those two days that I spent with
him I really was just taken with how how
kind and thoughtful and uh present uh a
young man he was and how much he he
admired and loved loved you it was
palpable you're and and you said
something to me you know about lost time
and you just got to be with him and and
I just can you just talk a little bit
more about fatherhood and and what it
means to you and and and how it serves
you and how you serve it you know I just
came back from a trip um seeing my
youngest children which I don't um live
with in in Miami my children my young my
youngest are in Miami and then I have um
my uh two more uh my 13 year old in um
Los Angeles and then my son and there's
three moms right and I say that because
every every child and every mom is a
different situation you get me and but
the main thing is is never letting them
know that that I'm stopped that I
stopped you know that that I'm not gonna
stop loving them that I'm not gonna stop
being there they could be [__] 10
miles away they could be [__] 3 000
miles away but at the end of the day as
long as you're [__] there and and
it's that like the [__] the
challenges between Adrian between Bella
between Damiano and and Flocka I call
her or are completely different but I
think the the heart of it is just
[__] just being there for them in
that personal way and and being patient
and understanding you get me an
understanding too that children are
medicine bro children give our life
children give us [__] happiness right
like looking at my not looking at my
child on the beach you know when he has
this [__] stick he's like I'm gonna
plant a tree right here like you're so
committed bro and like they're so pure
bro and we were that yeah yeah we were
pure you get me but bit of life has
[__] us up and made us [__] think
and see things you know and and it's
that bro just cherishing those moments
and and and that's how kind of how I try
to approach you know all my children
yeah yeah what do you want to do well my
bro I think I've I've over a decade of
of um being in the industry right and
film and television and and truly
understanding
um that film and television
um is not the craft of acting right and
it doesn't give me that thing that I
talked to you about in the theater and
if I'm not receiving that feeling in the
theater or whatever that is in a real
way then
then this thing could kill my joy
right I
I don't want the joy of acting to be
killed bro
because of the industry can you give me
an example of when that's when you've
smelt that
my last show
my last show was time to go
and things change right and I felt that
it was it was done bro after the joy is
gone right for whatever reasons whether
it's money whether it's power one when
when things start getting in front of
the story it is time to [__] go for
me right I don't give a [__] what soul
Runner what [__] director what star
it's time to [__] go that there
should be no reason to treat people
unjustly there should be no reason to
[__] to to feel that your power that
you could do whatever the [__] you want
on a show and that should never happen
and I can't speak on the behalf of
everybody but I could be it's been on
behalf of me now when that happens it's
time to [__] go do you feel that I I
get what you're saying about the theater
and I'm I'm with you 100 right
um there is a a pulverization of
hierarchy in the theater yeah awesome
there's no such thing as a small role
right the audience is just as important
as the people on stage it is a group
I understand that once you get into
um
just in terms of the economics of how
film and television are made that that
it can be poisoned quickly right right
um lick it bro we love the craft of
acting bro that the what is what does it
do why what the [__] does this thing do
right I believe that it has the power to
not only heal myself but it has the
power to heal the audience right or not
even heal them right but at least open
their [__] minds
by the time you get it on [__] film
and television bro has so tainted
Executives have pissed all over it right
the essence of what that [__] true
story is
is gone right why because someone
because we need a sexy scene or we need
a little [__] whatever right whatever
to [__] to make it more spicy to
[__] Hollywood and sexy to net
whatever [__] station you're in it's
that boy it's it's and and I'm tired bro
I'm tired you get me like like right now
I'm Reinventing myself but I have
started my my coffee company and this
shit's [__] crap going off right now
bro and I what's your coffee company
Coffee Company bro and we got our first
brick and mortar in the City of Pasadena
and Colorado and what did why I say this
bro that if it's one of the greatest
moments of my life right now bro because
I've been giving to others
now I'm giving to myself beautiful
I don't want any of your energy I've
given all my energy and I've seen what
you guys do to my energy I've seen when
I put my heart and soul I see how you
guys [__] feel about that and [__]
you [__] you for not respecting my heart
and soul [__] you for not respecting
that I [__] fasted for [__] six
months my body I [__] lost weight
deprived myself right and if you don't
respect it [__] you I'm done baby this
is all me right here this all I want all
my energy for myself now
and what can I what can I create I don't
know but I'm about to find out I'm about
to [__] find out right because if I
could create all this out of prison with
what can I catch you do the same way
that you talked about cutting off the
bakery and cutting that was thinking
yeah Hollywood baby
but when you say Hollywood
yeah we're part of it brother we're part
of Hollywood that's what you nasty
[__] that's right you're nasty
[__] [__] you fools right
that's right straight up that's right if
if it's that bro people [__] taking
advantage of people that's right that's
right and if you don't say anything
you're just as guilty [__]
that's right if you don't say anything
and the [__] is happening [__] you too
baby that's right and I don't want
nothing to do with you bro if you're
there blowing in and if a woman or a man
right it's getting taken advantage and
you're [__] turning amen [__] you man
amen [__] you amen amen and so so so
tell me in terms of the building so I
understand what we're we're turning our
backs on I understand that that's no
longer a part of what are we building
what are we building as artists
space to [__] a safe space brother
and to be [__] proud and [__] and
and not have that outside world
influence you or whatever is going on
that's it bro I want this this is this
is what you created right this is that
that's all I want for people to be able
to [__] enjoy themselves and and and
you want to have a dinner you want to
have a [__] podcast whatever bro my
te Pito is my essence of what Homeboy
Industries now
it's that I'm higher I have homies there
bro you know what we have a training
program bro like everything that is
happening that that homeboys does we are
doing at the bito so it's it's like what
do you want to do what what don't you
want to do type of [__] tell me what you
want to do I want to know specifically
man as an artist as an artist I
understand that there's art in what
you're doing with the cup but like I
also I have I have [__] worked with
you homie like I know what you give as
an actor you're not you're not you're
not done with that okay bro no no no no
no no no you're not done with that
people in this World brawl that have
access to me as an actor right now and
two of them are sitting in this room
it's you and my lady
that like that's it I just want to [__]
with you know like bro like whatever the
[__] you want to do or you know what I'm
saying it's gonna be [__] it's that
because you're gonna give your heart and
soul whatever my girl wants to talk it's
going to be because she's gonna give her
heart and soul people that you ride with
like the people that you ride with your
throats
I'm gonna want you you ain't supposed to
be here amen straight up bro I don't
need new friends I'm with you tell me
about your lady man
[Music]
I mean
I throw she she's [__] so smart bro
and I just I don't even wanna [__] bro
she's just [__] yeah bro I I I mean
she season three was I'm just gonna say
this bro season three
was my greatest [__] season of Mayans
bro and I honestly feel because she was
there for me in the writing for me we
weren't with each other at that time bro
so she was just there as a [__]
creative and as a friend and I was able
to [__] truly be vulnerable and be
able to give one of the greatest
performances that I have done in my life
on season three okay so hang on man this
is heavy to me because uh just from flow
inside of baseball but I don't give a
[__] I'm just talking to you man so so
she's a writer on the show you're an
actor on the show and and from being on
on shows you know the relationship
between the actors and the writers if
anything you know it's uh you know I
mean for me it's always contentious
because I'm like no I'm not saying that
[__] and like I'm sorry but like how how
how does that then become person I mean
I guess you would she's on set sometimes
like how does that happen yeah yeah she
was on set she was on set and but was
there something beautiful about the kids
she wrote for you in a certain way that
made you say like who the [__] is this
human it like can you walk through that
importantly it's not but she was on sale
on set right and most
important like she like you want an
apple
yeah maybe it was just that you wanna
you want some almonds you know you got
your eggs you eat your almonds today bro
and it's just like yeah bro and it was
that like just somebody being there that
cared you know and after nothing
happened but I after we you know it was
completely after bro and I mean we're 11
days apart but [__] was born on the same
it was crazy okay so but we went to the
same High School bro yeah that's crazy
type of [__] yeah and I don't like bro
like I believe in the spirit world bro I
follow the [__] what what the spirit
world but one of the same high school
didn't [__] know each other she went
to Colombia I went to California
Department of Corrections
bro what the [__] yeah on the same show
though yeah yeah 20 years later yeah
yeah born [__] yeah literally 80 same
year 1983 11 days apart bro I was like
what the [__] so you you guys like hey
come out to Joshua Tree
I was like all right jumped on the
[__] Harley went up to Joshua Tree
bro [__] was all over bro if anybody
knows about Joshua Tree yeah mushrooms
and Joshua Tree
a necessity bro
it's a necessity for any good
relationship I'm with you on that I'm
with you on that what do you love about
him
now this motherfucker's got neither one
my patience she says I'm a patient man
bro
[Applause]
oh man it's it's it's it's beautiful but
I know what I do love about her is that
like it's crazy right because we're both
um Mexicans born here right so we had
really no connection to Mexico
and what I love about her is that like
during this time of our life like we've
been in Mexico like so much now right
and we're going back to your mother
country does to you and I think for both
of us we've just been traveling but she
went with me and it's beautiful because
she's been with me she was the first one
to go me to the farm to to the coffee
Farm you know and and um and it's just
that you know getting a deeper
understanding from our people
um and enjoying it together bro you know
I I believe that being separated from
your your your your people and your
culture it [__] you up you know I'm not
saying that you have to like oh I am all
this but truly understanding understand
your culture bro like bro like I'm a
Mexican roller I I never knew there was
[__] pyramids in my [__] country
bro like what the [__] bro like that
[__] was crazy when I went there you
know what I'm saying like so it's it's
this this the separation that has been
for all cultures European cultures too
bro like you're not just an American bro
you're [__] there's this this huge
thing and like that has been a huge my
spirituality book my reconnecting to who
the [__] I am has been a huge influence
in who I am today beautiful
one of my first things that I did after
I um became established right one of my
first programs at Homeboy Industries was
called the all heart class right where
it was a free I trained whoever wanted
to come bro I just [__] like whoever
comes and [__] will do scenes and I'm
gonna walk you what a scene is and and
it would be the I remember my first
because my first exercises bro what I
would just be like get on the stage
and talk
talk and I was just like well tell me
about that what happened and when you
once you when people start talking you
could see what they want to talk about
give me a little bit of that give me a
little bit of that right well you know
it they're crying bro you know and not
because of me I didn't do [__] yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you just and and
boom we're just there we're all quiet
we're all honoring them
changes Paul completely change I have
Benjamin Levy right he's um he was one
of the one of the guys that I mentored
right and to see him you know as a
series regular now you know and just to
see in in
um some of them became stand-up
comedians you know what I'm saying some
of them became went back to their job
but it didn't matter but they left with
something that they didn't have and what
was that it was a space to express you
get me and like that's it like we have
held on to these dark secrets or these
things that have happened to him if you
keep them in
yeah but if you let them out
she changes here and I believe that's
what what art does especially on this
side
uh yeah man I
bro I I I appreciate you you coming and
doing this question of course it's it's
a real honor man and and uh I love that
you and I have have reconnected and and
uh I don't know man I just there's a lot
more to come man and I I consider it a
blessing I'm proud to be here thank you
man yeah yeah I love you bro thank you
thank you for doing this
foreign
[Music]